[MUSIC]
SPEAKER: Some obligations
arise from consent.
If I hire someone to paint my house,
and he does so, I'm obligated to pay.
But can obligations also arise
without an act of consent?
Consider the story about the
18th-century Scottish philosopher David
Hume.
Hume owned a house in Edinburgh.
He rented it to his
friend James Boswell,
who in turn sublet it to a sub-tenant.
The sub-tenant decided that
the house needed some repairs.
He hired a contractor to do the
work without consulting Hume.
The contractor made the repairs
and sent the bill to Hume.
Hume refused to pay on the
grounds that he had not consented.
He hadn't hired the contractor.
The case went to court.
The contractor acknowledged
that Hume had not consented.
But the house needed the repairs.
And he had performed them.
The court ruled in the contractor's
favor and required Hume to pay him.
Put aside whatever the law
might have been at the time.
How would you have decided the
case from a moral point of view?
Do you think that Hume is morally
obligated to pay this contractor?
[MUSIC]